we are Groot oh yes this was something
that at this point I had legitimately
kind of resigned myself to not ever
happening James Gunn has been rehired by
Marvel and Disney to make guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 oh okay
slight recap on the off chance that
people don't know what the heck went
down in the first place so James Gunn is
a filmmaker and has been for a while he
came up in the late 90s as part of Troma
which is very much not only shocked but
shocked cinema that's kind of their
whole thing and he wrote and more reason
what's most famous for now is both
writing and directing guardians of the
galaxy one and two and he was all set to
start working on guardians of the galaxy
three he had actually finished the
script and it got approved and they were
about to start pre-production when there
was basically a it turned out in
hindsight to be a fairly organized and
targeted and very specifically motivated
group of people who went back through
whose social media feed dug up stuff
from years he might have even been like
a decade ago it was like a long the
years and years ago where he made jokes
about rape and pedophilia and things of
that nature and they then stirred up a
controversy and in the wake of that
Disney cut him loose and since then the
movie guardians of the galaxy 3 has kind
of been in a limbo state now there were
calls to rehire James Gunn almost
immediately once it became clear that
this was very much a hit job and how
dated these things were and the fact
that James Gunn has never been
implicated in any kind of actual CDs
goes on what he
was make very bad jokes about it that
were while I'm not gonna defend those
jokes that they're not good jokes
they're not funny but they were very
much in keeping with the persona and
artistic stampy hat at the time that he
made him as I said the guy came up in
trauma trying to be a provocateur was
what he tried to have his brand be for a
while something that he eventually grew
out of and he was very upfront he never
defended these statements and I think
that's that's one of the reasons that
people continued to be on his side for
quite for quite a while um because he
was never defensive about this he never
lashed out at Disney he never even got
derogatory towards the people that dug
this stuff up
he said look yes this was stuff that I
said it was inappropriate but I did say
it and if people feel I shouldn't be
here because I said that stuff a while
ago okay and that was pretty much how he
handled it which I think that incredibly
high level of professionalism is
probably a big part of why Disney has
finally been able to pull him back in
now if the question if you have the
question why didn't they rehire him as
soon as it became clear that the
quote-unquote controversy was stirred up
in a very insincere way and there and
most reason people most reasonable
people wouldn't wouldn't be upset with
him continuing to work there well that
had mostly to do with corporate image
both of Disney as a brand and internally
initially it was fired because it was
feel it was worried that he was damaging
to the brand of Marvel and Disney but
when it became clear that well no none
of this is new this was all stuff that
Disney and Marvel already knew when I
heard him to do the first guardians
because I mean I can't imagine he wasn't
vetted so they all knew this then they
knew was far enough in the past but as
soon as stuff got stirred up they cut
him loose but the reason they didn't
bring him back right away was because of
basically the default internal logic and
sort of handling of things that Corp
executives executives have which is if a
mistake is made you you if you're the
one who makes a mistake you do not
reverse if somebody else makes mistaken
you have the power to reverse it okay
that's fine but you reverse your own
mistake even if you know it's a mistake
it makes you look weak and so it just
standard corporate culture said that it
was very unlikely that he was gonna be
hired back now as I said the movie had
been in a state of limbo for a while
because um it took a little while before
this happened but Kevin fide you did
eventually say that they were going to
keep James Gunn's script but that they
were still trying to find a director and
there had really been no word on that at
all there were rumors the big one was
was people room whirring that Taika
Waititi who directed thor ragnarok would
take over they turned out to be
absolutely no substance that rumor
whatsoever but it was a logical thing
because his sort of approach to the
Marvel as a barber he was not as
excessively dissimilar from guns so but
there really was nothing concrete and
Gahan himself I mean it felt like a done
deal when Gunn himself started booking
other gigs he's currently attached he's
working on right now Suicide Squad - so
with all that in place it seemed like
well they're never gonna get James come
back and actually so I completely
resigned myself to that and I had kind
of thought to myself you know there's a
pretty good chance this movie just never
happens because they won't find a
director willing to take it on because
either they you know they won't be able
to get a director of note with vision
because nobody will want to come in and
do what was very clearly supposed to be
James Gunn's movie especially because
they're gonna you know get a ton of crap
for whatever they do and Disney you know
say what you will about who they hired
how they handle things with Marvel they
for the most part they don't hire hacks
and that's the only kind of director who
would come in and take over this project
and they don't really go there so I was
starting to think that the movie was
just never gonna happen and now it's
back and that is confirmed that's not
where it's back actually turns out that
this move
has been in the works for a month
possibly a couple so they have been
quietly working behind the scenes like
getting things reimplemented and getting
him lined up again which the impression
this isn't gopher at least as of time of
recording the impression I get is that
Kevin Feige has probably been quietly
behind the scenes trying to move the
pieces in such a way that he could get
James Gunn back probably since this
entire thing went down and has just been
very strategic about it it's actually
kind of surprising to see especially
these days when the turn you may have
heard this term negotiating in the press
is kind of a big thing which is where
actors or directors or whatever sort of
basically say what they wish was
happening through interviews or open
letters or whatever to make it more
public and use that as leverage in fact
the cast of guardians of the galaxy
themselves actually did that Dave
Bautista being the most vocal say you
know saying we want these people back
and he said flat out if they get another
director I'm gonna see if there's some
way I can get out of my contract so
that's that sort of negotiating in the
press is is kind of becoming standard
operating procedures so the fact that
they reinstated him as quietly as they
did I'm pretty impressed now if you're
wondering when does this happen not for
a little while because James Gunn is not
leaving Suicide Squad - in order to make
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 he's still
going to make Suicide Squad to garnish
the galaxy 3 will be the next thing that
he makes and he should be able to jump
into it pretty quickly because as I said
scripts already done so he doesn't have
to do the early development stuff and
depending on how much sort of early
pre-production previz or whatever kind
of work had been done at the time he was
fired that may be able to start picking
up again basically in his absence and so
the ball can already be rolling as soon
as he's fresh off of Suicide Squad - and
this honestly is I mean it's just it's
just a relief because the whole
situation was very strange and Manhattan
dand then it was frustrating how it was
playing out and was looking like it was
going to end up ultimately being because
James Gunn as I said was incredibly
gracious he wasn't publicly angry I
wouldn't I mean if he was also privately
not angry than man huh
better person than I am but he certainly
wasn't publicly lashing out which I
think most people would have he wasn't
even being defensive you know he let the
fact that these statements were that
these statements that got dug up were as
old as they were and from a time where
at the time he said them that was his
public persona and he kind of let the
facts speak for themselves and just what
about his thing and but not in a way
that made it seem like he didn't care
but just well that's a shame
and he moved along and I think it says a
lot about his strength of character that
he was able to do that and another thing
about it that that is relieving to me
because one of the things that that I I
mean this was by far not the biggest
issue with Disney firing him and not
hiring back once the the details of what
went down became clearer but it sort of
wasn't play and it did frustrate me is
if people felt it was truly justified
where the stuff that he had said that
long ago was worth his firing from
something now when that has not been his
public persona in a very long time
creates a culture that discourages
personal growth because what's the point
in growing and changing and evolving if
you are forever going to be held to
account for something that you said
again
said not action not thing he did but bad
jokes in poor taste jokes that he made
years ago if you're forever going to be
held to account for that why would you
ever try and be a better person because
no one's ever gonna treat you like you
are and like I said that's far from the
biggest issue but speaking as someone
who has benefited a lot in my life from
people willing to extend me some benefit
of the doubt despite my own past
screw-ups yeah I think it's it's kind of
important to feel like you have the room
to change in that if you do people will
accept that so as much as this whole
situation was ridiculous I don't like
that it happened I don't like the
dragged out for as long as it did we
ultimately are going to get the
conclusion that I didn't dare to hope
for which which is we're going to get
the final installment of this story from
the guy who should be making it and who
I think has more than earned the right
to make it and yeah this was this was a
welcomed piece of good news on a day
that did not have a lot of good news and
this you know it sometimes it's hard for
me to make these videos you know knowing
other stuff that's going on in the world
outside of the stuff that I talk about
and I don't I oh god why am I doing this
I don't wanna I don't want to derail but
I feel there's a part of me that that
just feels the need to acknowledge that
like I dunno what else is going on I
know what happened in New Zealand and
this by no means suddenly makes this a
great day in history that this news
broke on the same day but it it was a
boost and it was nice to get and it's
silly and the grand scheme of things
it's stupid and superficial and in no
way can make up for other things that
are going on but it's a bit of good news
that I didn't think I'd ever see or have
and it made my day a little better and I
don't know if I've just brought
everybody's got this thing God what well
I think I'm just in a weird head space
today I don't know where like the whole
serious mood came in and white stayed or
what anyway James got his breakfast for
guardians of the galaxy holy crap oh I
gotta go to bed that's what I gotta do
what do you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about a whole bunch
of stuff to do buttons links patreon
Amazon wishlist is down there because my
birthday is coming up pretty dang soon a
little bit later this month there's a
p.o box there's other stuff to check out
give it all look or don't it is totally
fine if you don't click on any of those
folks
because you're not obligated you're the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]